come here come here help me out i feel
like we have so many books we have
nothing to read okay i read the girl on
the train four times okay and that came
out like what was that 20 years ago what
what's that book what is that the series
the
what is it the stormy the lightning what
is this oath binder
you know what i i think i'll give it a
shot but it's the third book in the
series well we can't all be winners
oh this brian sanders sure likes to
write huh is this caledon fellow the
good guy are we rooting for him
okay okay so you like these books
because everyone is depressed
hold on this is starting to get good did
you know that was gonna happen look i
was no fan of george bush but this
dalinar fellow is a war criminal i
wouldn't mind getting behind if you know
what i mean
really mom look all i'm saying is i
wouldn't mind seeing what goes on
beneath that shard plate okay
don't tell your dad how do you pronounce
it mosh moosh moash
oh okay [ __ ] him mom are you still up
you should shut the [ __ ] up
so you like the books because everyone's
depressed i get it now
[Music]
you